right we are delighted to have the
presidential candidate an independent
senator from Vermont Bernie Sanders is
with us as he has been many times on our
show never under such circumstances
Bernie you are a guy who has seen a lot
of things where do you place this crisis
in American history never in my lifetime
bill what we're looking at now is
absolutely unprecedented you know we're
looking at a pandemic the likes of which
we have not seen in a hundred years
we're looking at an economic collapse
that may may end up being worse than the
Great Depression with 30 40 million
people of becoming unemployed in the
next number of months so it's
unprecedented in our lifetimes that's
for sure and what would you do right now
if you were the president this is
exactly what I would do the main point
is that we have to prevent a breakdown
in the entire system that's how
dangerous it is right now it is much
easier to maintain the system than to
fix it after it is broken what does that
mean from an economic point of view it
means that we tell every worker in
America you will continue to get your
paycheck we know you're not working we
know you're at home you know your
business that you're working for is not
functioning but guess what we're gonna
do what the UK is doing what Denmark is
doing what Norway is knowing what France
is doing you will continue to receive
100% of your paycheck
number two what we have got to do is
guarantee that all people in America
during the crisis get the health care
they need without out-of-pocket expense
it is pretty crazy to say to people as
the last stimulus package did that you
can get your coronavirus test government
pays for that but if you're sick and go
to the hospital you have to pay for that
out of your own pocket number three what
we have to do is protect our health care
system right now we need to use the
defense production act
to tell the private sector will be
well-compensated
they must produce the masks the gowns
the gloves the ventilators that the
healthcare system requires also if we're
ever going to get back to normal we're
gonna need a new level of testing that
we have never seen before and I think we
can do it but we have to invest in it so
that it says to bill maher bill you have
been tested right now instantaneously
you are not spreading the virus you are
not going to be susceptible to the virus
you can go into a work environment with
other people who are clean as well so we
need to invest very heavily in testing
we also need to provide substantial help
to federal to state and local
governments because they are running out
of money we have helped them in the last
stimulus package we've got to do more in
the next stimulus package which we are
working on right now because if the cops
are not being paid the EMT people are
not being paid you're gonna have a
breakdown in the system and we have also
got to protect working families all over
this country who cannot afford right now
to pay their rent their mortgages their
student loans their auto loans and so
forth and put a freeze on those type of
payments so bottom line is Bill in my
view we are in an unprecedented moment
in American history we have got to act
in an unprecedented way and I am working
with other senators and members of
Congress on what will be an
unprecedented piece of legislation to
try to save this country
in such a difficult moment okay I mean
you mentioned getting a hundred percent
of your paycheck the criticism of you
has often been that you are promising
money that the government could not
possibly come up with how long can the
government do that how can we just keep
printing money isn't that a recipe for
economic disaster down the road
well I think bill by not preventing a
crisis you end up saving money and
easing a whole lot of pain in this
country I don't think you have an
alternative we are looking at some 30 or
40 million people over a period of
months of retreat maybe of you know
three four months losing their jobs and
if we do not do not protect those people
you're gonna see a a collapse of of the
economy and it will take us more money
to put it back together and what I'm
suggesting by the way is largely what is
already going on in the UK Germany
Norway Denmark and other countries so
it's not a kind of a new idea and by the
way we put that provision into the
recent stimulus bill for two million
workers in the airline industry while
the airline industry is virtually shut
down those workers will continue to get
a hundred percent of their paycheck and
their health care and their health care
which is what we should be doing so bill
I'm not suggesting to you and this is
not an expensive proposition I am
suggesting to you that the alternative
is worse I find one of the most galling
parts of this is that the president is
favoring certain states over the others
governors who are nice to him as he
calls it get a lot of attention and all
the equipment they want to me this is
even more of an impeachable offense than
what he did with Ukraine or Russia how
do you stop a president who is blatantly
not the president of every state equally
how do you stop a president who sends
aid to Florida for example because that
he likes the governor there but not here
to California or Illinois or
Massachusetts it is literally beyond
comprehension I mean you know we have a
president who has done so much harm in
this entire process who has downplayed
the crisis from day one which will cost
us that his actions or inactions in not
listening to the scientists and spouting
off ridiculous ideas isn't that going to
cost the lives of many
of Americans but to answer your question
Congress has got to step up to the plate
and step up big time and I will tell you
what else concerns me the worst part of
this two trillion dollar a stimulus
package of his passed last week and I
voted for it
but the worst part of it was 500 billion
dollars going to the President to
allocate to corporate America with no
when you the kind of strings attached an
accountability that should have been
required now he is saying hey I don't
really care about accountability oh I'll
do what I want and to pick up on your
point if you think that during a
campaign you're not gonna see a lot of
money from the Trump administration
going to battleground states -
Pennsylvania Michigan Wisconsin Florida
you would be grossly under estimating
the venality venality of this president
so these are issues we're going to have
to stay on and work very hard to correct
okay so during the campaign you and your
rivals debated many times who has the
better health care plan but my point has
always been that one thing I never hear
from a politician is saying to the
American people no matter what health
care plan we have it's not going to work
unless you take more responsibility for
your own personal health one reason
we're in the mess we're in is because
Americans are not very healthy to begin
with I know this is under the category
of never going to happen but if I was
president I would Institute a Manhattan
Project for getting our immune systems
in better shape and part of that is
suggesting very strongly that people eat
better food and less of it
would you agree absolutely I mean this
is exactly what the federal government
should be doing what the Surgeon General
should be doing look in the long run I
mean as you know we have seen a decline
in life expectancy I think for three out
of the last four years major crises with
diabetes with obesity with opioid
addiction with alcoholism with suicide I
mean we have many many problems and one
of the areas that concerns me very much
you have the food industry selling
absolute garbage to kids with all kinds
of sugar and everything else in it so
what we need is a government to work
hard in terms of disease prevention it's
not just food
it is exercise it is doing a lot better
in terms of mental health than we do
right now so disease prevention is
obviously the way to create a happier
more fulfilled society and also to say a
hell of a lot of money if we don't have
to deal with diabetes and obesity and
heart disease and all of the all of the
illnesses caused by poor diets and and
other things well I'm glad to hear you
say that all right our last question
it's a question I've asked other
candidates before I don't seem to ever
get a satisfactory answer but I'm
hopeful for you and that is this I've
been saying for a number of years that
if Trump loses the election he's not
going to leave now I notice a lot of
people are talking about this very issue
if you are elected president and Trump
gets out there and says well there were
irregularities and it was rigged and it
was this and it was that and I'm not
going anywhere until we find out what's
going on what do you do well you
mobilize the American people in a way
that they have never been mobilized
before to essentially remind this
president that whether he likes it or
not
we live in a democracy and that the
majority the American people through the
electoral process will determine who the
next president is so you know what
you're describing is a nightmarish
scenario with regard to democracy in
America do I think you're crazy and
off-the-wall I suspect not but I think
we have to make it clear from now on
throughout the campaign and the day
after he loses that if he loses this
election he will be out of office and
replaced by the new president well I am
crazy an off-the-wall but I'm always
happy when you join us on our show even
if it's remotely stay healthy out there
senator good luck with the campaign and
I hope to see you in person someday soon
okay you take care as well
Thank You Bernie
you